In Afghanistan, at least 14 people have been killed and about 40 wounded...
...after a suicide bomber struck an election rally...
...in the country's eastern Nangarhar province.
In Poland, more than 20,000 public safety workers gathered in Warsaw...
...to protest working conditions and to call for pay increases.
In Nicaragua, Violeta Chamorro, the first female president of Nicaragua,...
...was hospitalized and placed in intensive care Monday...
...following an apparent stroke.
In the US, Las Vegas police have reopened the investigation into a rape allegation...
...against soccer player Cristiano Ronaldo in 2009...
...after the victim came forward with new information.
Finally from Russia, a Russian prisoner has been released...
...after an investigation into a video that was released in July,...
...showing him being tortured.